we got our first glimpse of the fresh
prince of bel air's upcoming reunion
and apparently will smith worked
something out
that shocked us all
will smith posted this photo alongside
the fresh prince's
original aunt viv janet hubert they both
appear happy
signaling their decades of bad blood
could be behind them
will fighting doesn't solve anything oh
no there could be no fighting [ __ ]
will also included this shot taken
yesterday by the other surviving cast
members in their iconic living room
to commemorate the show's 30th
anniversary that's stephanie maxwell
reed who replaced hubert
after three seasons in 1993. so why is
this face-to-face with the og viv so
unexpected
well let me take you back okay now tell
me about the young will smith
why i've tried to recess it back into
the
the hell file she went nuts
long story short i seem to recall coming
to you and saying
maybe we could get a little raise and
your response to me
was my deal is my deal and your deal is
your
deal will has never publicly responded
to that claim
so we'll be popping the popcorn to hear
his side when the reunion special airs
on hbo max
now to some more tv drama last night on
big brother all-stars
because i'm talking calmly and you want
to yell how are you feeling emotionally
about that fight as you sit here today
you know what there's a lot of things
that are going through my head you don't
get to play a victim in this
situation you usually finish you know
you use me
a day after her eviction bailey dayton
spoke to us about what she feels is a
double standard for black players
this intense confrontation with
housemate christmas was the tipping
point
good game bailey wow what did i do if i
was clapping in somebody's face
i'm a ghetto black girl it's unfair she
does it it's unfair and she's fine she's
just upset
if you cuz her out everybody's gonna
blame you
oh god she's ignorant to our own
ignorance
if i were to do what christmas did this
is how we would be labeled and i hope
that eventually christmas sees
you know the difference between the way
she conducts herself in the way that we
conduct ourselves in the double standard
[Music]
there